Madam President, this ceremony could
not have started without a word of
welcome from those who
constitute the key actors of our
university, namely the students and
in particular the students
from our European programs the
European programs of the
Toulouse Capitole University  will join us
to welcome you
Massilia Sheila Yana Anthony they
wished with this madman that you
raised earlier this ardor of
our young student
from Capitole University to
welcome you to our
university with Mr. President
Ukensac
Madam  the President of the
European Commission, ladies and gentlemen, the
deputies and senators of Haute-Garonne and
the time of the guarantee,
President in charge in particular of
research into higher education in the
Occitanie region, Mr. President
of the Departmental Council represented by
Mr. Vice-President Vincent
Gibert Mr. Mayor Toulouse
represented by Mr. Assistant
responsible for higher education Ladies
and gentlemen mayors of Tournefeuille de
Fenouillet our mother Ladies and
gentlemen the elected officials
Ladies and gentlemen the consultants
Mr. Rector of
higher education Mr. Rector
of  Douala University Ladies and
Gentlemen Presidents of the universities
of the municipality Toulouse University
Mr. Director of Sciences Po
Toulouse Ladies and
Gentlemen Deans Vice-Presidents Ladies and
Gentlemen Presidents of other
jurisdictions Ladies and Gentlemen
professionals and who did not accompany him
in  our missions dear guests dear
colleagues dear and dear colleagues my
dear students
I am going to ask you to project yourselves
in 2033 in about 10 years we
are in the amphitheater of
the Toulouse Capitole University
Portal building which is the building which was
side under construction and
the enfier is full of people for the
solemn start of the University of
Toulouse in 2033
in this front it is a son there is an
allegave with the names of the doctors at
the Toulouse Capitole University the
first is that of planting in
honor of you dear Madam since
it is thanks to you that we are inaugurating
this and Toulouse Capitole University is
of course one of the best in the
world placed in the top 10 of the Shanghai ranking
and  of course thanks to its
world economy setting and thanks to its
management school thanks to its law school
transformed into this amphitheater
three students who were therefore
students in 2023 and who now have
functions
discuss how the
ceremony in 2023 of the doctoral discounts
at risk
I give the floor to one of them and
she will tell you what had
happened this year of 2023
it was a very beautiful ceremony and the
president of the commission had been
masterful  a real fighting woman
embodying Europe and university had
been honored by her hopeful presence
showing the importance of 30
towards a Europe always more a
Concordia
a variety
how we say it
oyo
and the President you trusted
for the introductory remarks,
the year 2023 had been very beautiful, it
had seen the university transformed into an
experimental public establishment with
Toulouse as its component establishment,
the best non-
Anglo-Saxon economics department in the world, but also the
Faculty of Law Sciences Po Toulouse la
Toulouse  cause management the Faculty
of Administration and Communication the
Faculty of Computer Science and the IUT of Rodez
the same year 2023 had been very rich
with the EQUIS label obtained
thanks to Toulouse management making
our university the second
public university to obtain it in  France and the
president of the university was delighted
with this fine result
also with the launch of the
transformation of the Faculty of Law into a
law school with the
progressive establishment of an entire
bachelor's and master's degree course entirely in
English language
in 2025 after hosting other
academic institutions,
Toulouse Capitole University has obtained the status of a
large establishment
with the contribution of the Occitanie region of
Toulouse Métropole and its partners
from the socio-economic world thanks to
the excellence of  its research and
training
Toulouse Capitole University had
become a major research university
contributing to making Toulouse and its
region a world reference for
higher education and
research in Europe with a
professional integration rate close to
100%
what a long way to go isn't
there but obviously I'm sorry
responsible within the
European Commission for Erasmus more in recent
years thanks to its own student this
Toulouse Capitole and international university
and each student  today participates in
an exchange with another
reinforced State instead of the same one of the 4
academic initial student training
also professional training
in all sectors today
thanks to racism plus
Toulouse Capitole University
to follow to double them  international diplomas
the dream of the pedestrian woman
today Toulouse
Capitole University is one of the
most glassy universities in Europe like cancer
Anthony as the leader of an
intervironmental organization I
may confirm the remarkable evolution with
the help of the Commission and its
Greenville our university has served as
an example by participating in
soft mobility and by implementing
a vision of and meetingless and absorbs
moreover the university Toulouse
Capitole 1 has contributed to safeguarding
of ecosystems in
urban areas it has promoted self-sufficiency by
having its own internal agricultural space
it has established as a dogma the fact of
favoring short circuits it has
been supported by the majority of
European universities and thanks to it
all of Europe  guessed the goal
of being carbon neutral by 2050
today Toulouse
Capitole University is a benchmark for
gender equality and inclusion is
n't it Chila indeed as an
international business advisor
at  the commission I can confirm that
this cause has made progress, particularly in the
economic field and we can say a
power woman
the Toulouse Capitole University has
established a recruitment policy
based on parity the fight against
gender stereotypes and in addition
the university  Toulouse Capitole has
established an effective policy
of inclusion and ensuring
equitable access to higher education
as for me, I am a diplomat in the
European External Action Service the
conflict in Ukraine had been a
highlight
our university with had created with
d  other universities a
partnership foundation with, in particular, the
mission should be for peace and to
help students from States which
had gone through a difficult ordeal
such as war or drought
president
had taken the floor
again thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen the president of the
European Commission welcome to this
university of academic excellence
of modern social excellence open to
Europe and the world which welcomes
colleagues and students in particular
from  Ukraine of Afghanistan of Iran of Sudan
a university which tries to articulate
the excellence of French-style public service
and
international standards a university which responds
to the challenge of the 21st century a university that is
never pretentious sometimes proud
very ambitious but always always
human  welcome to this university
in this beautiful amphitheater thank you
[Applause]
madam President ladies and gentlemen
dear students this ceremony
continues with a presentation which will
be in the form of animation but
also of presentation because this
university of project of
innovative projects you will have some  here the
main variations through
different
objectives concerning the structuring of
research at the international level the
real estate strategy the
digital transformation of our university and
lifelong learning
but also the creation of a
partnership foundation to
enable us to  have an effective interface
with our social and economic partners,
particularly present here in the assembly,
so first of all the international research center
the international
[Music]
is already our university, but this
element will be consolidated and reinforced
in  the coming months to speak
now about the real estate strategy of
our university I call Mr.
Vice-President in charge of heritage
Mr. Professor Jean-François
jacuzzo
[Applause]
Madam President Ladies and gentlemen
you know it you see it today  today
the Toulouse Capitole University is under
construction but for a long time this
university under construction is a
university which builds it transports
in stone its ambitious
institutional projects and to extend a
recent word from president kenfuck these
real estate projects must have a better
impact on society on  the community
which project for which community in the
first place of course the community of
the university itself
the university accompanies the projects of
these component establishments and of its
components the manufacture of tobacco is
partly made available to
the Institute  political studies with
the financial aid of the State and
local authorities the university
built under contracting authority a
building which is now
available to the Toulouse school made
economic and a building which has become
emblematic for the city center  of
Toulouse
to support the development of
sports practice and teaching
within the university a new
building is being constructed
today on the land reserves
of the university
to support the projects of its
law faculties components of its
components Toulouse of management the
programming of an ambitious operation
of demolition reconstruction of a
building in the city center and launched today
this operation is courageous because
the university commits its
financial reserves on this project
other projects are at the  study but to
date are not funded they
will improve working conditions
study conditions on campus and deepen
synergies with the
socio-economic world
think in particular of this beautiful project
of Maison des Métiers
what a project for  which community
secondly the real estate policy
an impact on our
territorial community and more specifically on the Toulouse
community
Toulouse Capitole University is a
city center university a university open to
the city the university has
ambitious projects for its students  but also
for its territory it builds
emblematic buildings participate in the
improvement of the living environment in the
greening of the city takes up the
environmental and societal challenges
today posed to the real estate project
which project for which community
thirdly and lastly the community
of  partners of the university
they are invited to invest with
the university in the future of the students
and of its territory and their
territory the metropolis co-finances
places of soft mobility on the campus
it already participates in the
cultural promotion of the university by organizing
events in these buildings
other partnerships can be forged
for the future of students and the
territory and recent studies
show that one euro invested in
the university one euro invested in
university real estate contributes
to
socio-economic development  of a territory and this
is particularly true for our
university located in 7 in the city center
which has created real synergies with
these merchants
in conclusion you have understood that
building with the Toulouse
Capitole university means building a community
community a strong community a
community confident in the future a
community which here as elsewhere is
united in diversity thank you
university the digital transformation
of our university continuing education
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
fourth pillar of these
structuring projects is the creation of a
partnership foundation with our
social and economic partners
[Music]
here is Madame  the President Ladies and
gentlemen in a few words
some suggestions of our various
structuring and innovative projects of
our university Madam President
we are the Toulouse
Capitole University and honored by your presence the
president of the university will now
evoke the plural motivations for
which the  Toulouse
Capitole University confers on you today the
honorary doctorate Coza which will make
you a full member of our
university community
[Applause]
dear Madam President of the
European Commission
when Henri IV who was born at the foot of the
Pyrenees so close  received the help
of Elisabeth 1st during her accession to the
throne of France
he could not help shouting
what woman
and what queen and yet we know that at
that time women in general did
not have as many rights of
freedom  and legitimacy that today
the very fact that thus lays down arms
before the one who reigns over the oceans
and the seas had become the
most powerful sovereign of the
Western world, so we measure everything he
put in this cry of  admiration
creation precisely
we cannot fail to feel for
you and we do not really know in what
order it is necessary to exclaim it
which woman which mother which minister
and since you are linked to the
European Commission which president
Viviane reading  who was
European Commissioner from 2004 to 2014 described you
one day and I quote as a mistress
woman who is now modern in view of the
traditional culture in which
she has blessed
your private life as well as your
public life, it is indeed striking to
see how  you are determined and
how you knew how to go after
your convictions often take the
opposite view of your education of your
political camp and sometimes even of your
country
another subject of astonishment finally for us
you did not commit until very late
in politics at the age of 43
after a first career as a doctor
sees public health
nevertheless you were born in a family
where public affairs occupied a
very important place your hand
Idy Adèle stromaeer and as a doctoral student
language German literature and your
father a  dirty breach in the cabinet
of a European commissioner in Brussels
then president of Landes you
often say it at home and I quote you we
talked a lot about politics
you were also impregnated with
European questions because until the age
of 13  we had it compared in
my office you did not live in
Germany but in Brussels because of
your father's responsibilities Europe
its diversity you carry it in your
heart
your first fights you lead them in
terms of family policy in a
country Germany or the place of the woman
from the sea of ​​the wife may seem
different voices very different from what
it is in France as well as the
place of the child in a country where the
birth rate for several decades is
has become an important subject of
concern
concerning precisely the place of
women, a subject that concerns you in the
first place, your action was
fundamental as Minister of
Social Affairs for the Langue de Bassins from 2003 to
2005, then as Federal Minister responsible in
particular for the family during the
first  term of office of Angela Merkel from
2005 to 2009
you undertook
important reforms and your years in another
prefigured the mission that the Chancellor
entrusted to you later
to redefine the family policy of the country
defines a family policy
of Germany what a vast program
but this family policy of combat
you have elasated it at the federal level and
nothing could let think really
nothing when one reads your course that
you would leave in campaign against the
traditional family model carried by
pala Germany carried by your own
party the  CDI and sometimes it must be said taking into
account the intentions of the Chancellor
herself I will come back to it it must be said
that your life in itself is a real
manifesto
on the one hand you have been able to combine a rich
family life with a trajectory a
professional trajectory  exemplary
how many people know here that you
raised this child all musicians
as it should be in Germany to the point
of being able to form a small
chamber orchestra and too bad if during
television interviews the
then
three-year-old little Gracia starts crying  a
little too loud in the next room or
if the if the office of the Minister
train bear puzzles in addition in
2005 one lived you are still
regional minister and you declare that would be a
catastrophic sign for Germany
it is  a high office like that of the
minister was not reconcilable with the
fact of having children you will be
really right on the other hand you have
always known how to get out of the clichés
to break the prejudices and this exemplary
you have put it at the service of your
fellow citizens women and men and sometimes
we risk displeasing your
political friends your best friends one of
your traits characters is your strength
of conviction which transcend
appearances partisan affiliations
the compartmentalization of our time the
compartmentalization which was exceeded in 2007
in particular  you impose two major
societal measures firstly you
introduce parental leave
benefiting both parents and going
up to 14 months and secondly you
will make many people dream
in the room the same year you create
500,000 places in crèches
it's one between us come back
and by the way you pay
homage to France and you say in
social matters Germany has learned a lot
from France in particular from its
family policy and the
reconciliation of family and
professional life obviously the reactions
are not unanimous
but you have not experienced it you know that
despite everything you won an
important battle that of public opinion
later in 2013 you defend the
creation of a system of compulsory quotas
accumulated for women 30% of the seats in the
within the boards of directors of
large German companies
there too you have a very
strong opposition but you will obtain it moreover
at the cost of a political crisis by
associating yourselves with deputies of what one
can call the left to impose
finally, even though I am
still saying it, the chancellor she was by the
employers was a little reluctant here
again your position is not that
of your party but to
once again reinforce your status as a
woman of conviction
you are called  another ministry, but
these are not a big deal for you because
you continue to defend within the
federal government the
societal measures that you consider necessary
you are in particular in favor of
adoption for same-sex couples
and in 2017 you are one of the  75
deputies of the CDI out of 300 who vote in
favor of marriage for all
these eight years in the Ministry of the
Family commissioner of labor of
social affairs opens for the
fighting woman that you are on a new
stage on December 17, 2013 you are
appointed Minister appointed to the Ministry of Defense
you are thus you will always be the
first the first woman in history
to lead the famous green Bundes
in French
for historical reasons we know
how sensitive the military question is
or very nevertheless you do
your  founding statements by
President Joakim Gogh at the
Munich Security Conference in
2014 and I quote the consequences of
inaction may be more serious than
that of action for you Germany
is ready to do its part  in the
resolution of international crises
six years old you increase the
defense budget by 40%
.  it is quite natural that in 2019 at
the end of the mandate of Jean-Claude Juncker
the head of the European Commission the
German Chancellor and the
French President easily agreed on
your name
while in you indeed because Europe your
origins your  childhood in Brussels your
mastery of the European language your
vast culture even better you are
Europe
even in the first names of your seven
tasty children
who we know otherwise but
it is before Brexit so we can
understand and we can accept
Gracia to ring too  well Italian
Spanish so beyond that you have
acquired the conviction that
Victor Hugo's dream the United States of Europe
will have to come true and you say very
clearly if my children will
perhaps not rise there you are careful my
grandchildren  them you are affirmative
will raise
moreover as Minister of Defense you
have several times paid for your wishes for
the creation of a European army
formula troubling for many
people in many countries of Europe
what conception do you have of
the  Europe
the major crisis that you had to
face from your first months at the
head of the commission the
global pandemic followed by the outbreak of
war in Ukraine have a case put your
convictions you need a strong Europe a
Europe that protects
we think then  that although the
Protestant tradition for this may be recalled
here the great protective cloak that we
often find in the
representations of your patron saint scene
in Germany St. Ulysses from
Cologne but since the
Munich security conference how much
founding you  have acquired the
conviction that Europe must be
both able to act and determine and
tell you moreover in view of the
global challenges terrorism poverty climate
change Europe must
accelerate what wanted the chorus
you say we must go  faster
and you add those who want it
must be able to move forward be able to move forward
forgiveness without being blocked by others
to our you are convinced that the
Franco-German couple is not a
vestige of the past it is of the present it
remains and still and  always the bedrock
of Europe and I quote you no
group in the world is in the
situation to get along so
intelligently to solve its problems
the Franco-German couple you say
this one is lying it's beauty and
beauty the European Union
naturally when a lively debate in
Germany to give up the seat of the
European Parliament Strasbourg you
respond firmly it is one of the
symbols of
Franco-German reconciliation it is the fruit of a
long history we do not  cannot erase
such a symbol
no from the second speech of the State of
the Union in September 2021 you had to
prosto do so the deputies of
Strasbourg and beyond the heads of state
of European government and beyond
public opinion and  I quote you you
can have the most
advanced forces in the world but if you are
never ready to use them what is the
use of it you perhaps did
not think then that we have a half later the
war would break out in the  doors of
Europe since the beginning of this crisis
which constitutes for our Europe a
major risk of dislocation you show
courageous avant-ghadist examples
from April 9, 2022 to grow in
Ukraine in the village Marty and you
declare your fight and our fight at the
European leader who hesitates
not really knowing in which direction
they should go
you are advancing without ambiguity it is a
war against our values ​​against our
future if Russia is going to sink into
economic, financial and
technological decomposition Ukraine, you say,
march towards  a European future that's
why my students imagine that it
will take place next year the year
after but we will come back to it on May 9
for Europe Day you are going
to Kiev for the fifth time  and
even though some say to themselves that we are going to
try to find a solution you are
refining the sanctions are not ready
to be lifted on time and with
determination through appeasement
but the war in Ukraine despite its
gravity
is  my solidarity with the people
of Ukraine has not overshadowed
the other challenges that the group has to
face, in particular climate change
in the first month of your President, you
make the Ecological Pact or the Green Deal
the centerpiece of your mandate  the
ecological transition will have to concern
all the policies of the
European Union and making Europe the
first carbon neutral continent
by 2050 becomes your
absolute priority and you put it into practice
in all the decisions you
take for yourself at this moment  strong has no
equivalent he is a
specialist in Europe and
European law in the room realize
that the equivalent horn of a
European adventure is the one who at 70 years old
led to the European Community
coal and glacier
at the same time you turn towards a
land that tries you which is
also dear to me Africa for your first
official trip the president of the
European Commission you choose at
10 in Beba the seat of the European Union
and you come back there  2 months later
accompanied by 20 commissioners, i.e.
almost all of the government of
Europe and you are leaving aside you
are right the historical rhetoric is
outdated on development aid because
it is now a question of asserting oneself as a
partner  natural and I quote you to
face together the common challenge
peace security
climate change the digital transition for
Europe there is an urgent need to create one in
Africa in the face of the ambitions of China,
Russia, the United States  from
Turkey and the Gulf countries and you
say I quote you again we have
a common destiny many our priorities
coincide
and as always with you it is one of
you very character acts follow
the parents and in February 2022 during the
European Union Africa summit
African Union in Dakar the Africa Europe plan
decides on 150 billion euros
of investment and the end of your
speech is very clear without ambiguity
and I quote you again our two
unions share the same vision that of
creating a  common area of ​​stability and
prosperity,
but there are still in Europe to
return to Europe the societal challenges
when the Commission was set up
in 2019 you have 19 men appointed
for 12 women against 9 women for 19
women previously we did not have  not done
better in terms of parity at this level you
also want to include in the
European treaties violence against
women as a crime and on the occasion of the
second speech of the State of the Union you
enter the hemicycle the symbols are
important alongside an
Italian fencer Béatrice Viaud to crown
a few weeks earlier at the
Paralympic Games in Tokyo a
striking image of a challenge that is close to your
heart that we share in this
university that of inclusion
more than ever it's madam  the
President of the European Commission
our European ideal is
threatened today and we must thank you for
always regenerating it in all these
dimensions and in this you join here
another convinced European our
national treasure Edgar Morin studying in our
university in 1941 who will be  moreover
in a few days in our walls on
June 24th and who concludes his
major book think Europe with these words the
salvation of Europe is in the
regeneration of these founding principles
and in this century of confrontation of the
superpowers in  the conquest of its
autonomy thank you for
tirelessly maintaining this flame
welcoming you today dear Madam
President of the
European Commission as an
honorary doctor from the University Toulouse
Capitole is a great honor for us
for the university of course for these
component establishments
economic latitude Sciences Po Toulouse we said
earlier for its components of the
Faculty of Law and
Political Science the Toulouse color
management the faculty of computer science the
Faculty of administration and
communication the IUT of Rodez for all
these  partners here an important element
our European orientation is already
very old the presence of our
students from European programs,
in particular Franco-German, is there to
remind us that our commitment to Europe
must be long-term our
European university in essence has
participated in  the creation
of the European Alliance ntage whose
objective is to respond to
societal sheets and there within it a
European dynamic under the flora which
trains lawyers by and for Europe
and it is the only
French establishment to have obtained in 2017  the
Jean Monnet center of excellence label of
promoter without those he had in the
room it has more than 150
European partnership partners and no less
than twenty double degrees with
European universities even beyond
Europe it  has forged
very important partnerships with many
universities around the world, particularly in
Africa, in which it
works following the initiators who
are in the room at the creation of an
association of university towns
in Africa with the aim of  ambition to
always contribute to its development
thanks to excellent research and
effective training our
university is resolutely committed to
meeting the societal challenges of today
and tomorrow, in particular health, the
environment, equality, inclusion
l  artificial intelligence it is
therefore in full alpha with your action
this day of June 9, 2023 must remain
for us a stage and a mark of which
we are happy and proud know from
the President of the
European Commission that you will always be
welcome in this
Toulouse university, one of the oldest
in Europe, founded in 1229 and which, along with
Bologna Oxford padouf Salamanca,
constitutes another of the
founding stones of the European ideal a
university which is now also
yours thank you
[Applause]
being an honorary doctor c'  is a
multiplicity of symbols that will be
summoned here to mark your
membership of our
university community in the first place it is
a diploma as Mr. President
of the University Toulouse Capitole will
give you
Mr. President
Madam President
[Applause  ]
to this diploma is added the delivery of an
academic dress the gown that will be
given to you by Professor Marion
Fortin, Vice-President in charge of
international relations and in particular
of the United Alliance
[Applause]
here is
this cage must be completed by
the epitoche and I call
Professor Gentirol Nobel Prize
in Economics to give the pizzas to
the President of the European Commission
[Applause]
Mr Deputy Rector,
please give a trophy to Madam
President  of the European Commission
[Applause]
and to complete this panorama, I call on
two key players cooperating with our
university, Madam Vice-President of
the Region, Mrs. Figue, to
provide you with a book related to the
Occitanie region as well as a key player
in  our city in the presence of the
deputy of the mayor of Toulouse
of the metropolis Mr Maxime clairvoyant
in order to also deliver a work
relating to our life of this house
[Applause]
very well
Senator Lévy we
call you  now to offer
the President a bouquet of flowers
[Applause]
an accident has happened
a crisis managed tomorrow to put it
is a small crisis forgive us I am
now calling Mrs. Estelle
Galand university professor in order to
put back  a book on the
German Constitutional Court and the
work of a colleague, Ms. Aurore
Gayet,
who is also present here to
deliver this book
dear Aurore dear Estelle
Aurore is coming
[Applause]
Madam President Ladies and gentlemen,
we are coming to the long-awaited moment of
this ceremony this  certainly a
moving moment for this assembly madam
President doctor Noris cosa we are listening to you
thank you very much
dear president
uken fac
madam vice-president of the
Occitanie Region Madam pellefi Dear
representative of the institutions in your
respective capacities dear professors
members of staff dear students of
the  Université de Toulouse Capitole
ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for your warm welcome,
it is an immense honor to receive this
doctorate from nurse Kawasaki,
you are not only one of the
oldest universities in
Europe and the world,
but also the  he one of the best
academic and
research establishments in France and in Europe
today
I am convinced that it is not by
chance that you find yourself in the
beautiful city of Toulouse the pink city
the city of violets
a city founded on the  heritage of its
long history
but also on its ability to innovate and
look to the future
and your university is a reflection of
this city
it has dynamic economically
scientifically culturally
its dynamism and draws it from you gathered here
but also from its inhabitants and  all
those who come from all over the world to
work in your cutting-edge industries,
you are in many ways a good
illustration of our European project,
a project based on the rich heritage
of our past
and on the dynamism of our contemporary societies
and allow me
to  dwell on two personalities
attached to the history of Toulouse
last night I had the privilege of
visiting the home of one of them
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry
not only the author that we
all know
but also the pilot  daring
he arrived as a young man in Toulouse in the
mid 1920s
in pursuit of a dream
he joined a group of aviators
who were setting up the first
French air mail service the airport
their goal was not just
to  transporting mail between
continents but bringing people together
this dream was also pursued by the
second figure that I want to mention
the founder of Aéropostale
a real son of Occitanie Pierre
Georges Latécoère
at the beginning of the beginning of the adventure hour  he
said i quote
i redid all the calculations our idea
is unrealizable
we only have one thing left to
do make it
happen
and that is exactly what they did
in a few years they set up
the first  connection with Morocco
after they crossed Africa
the Atlantic and the waves
overcoming unthinkable obstacles
for small planes of the time
here after flight they pushed the
limits of what was possible
this is the spirit of this  city ​​and it is
also the spirit of the founders of our
European Union
the history of our union is to
achieve
what seems impossible
after centuries of European war
decades of peace
after the destruction of our continent
an area of ​​unprecedented prosperity
after the dictatorship
a refounding of democracy
our founding fathers and our
founding mothers showed audacity to
overcome the imperfection of what is
and see the beauty of what could
be
this same mixture of creativity,
pragmatism and determination
is more  that ever at the heart of the European project
this mixture is essential to chart
the future of current and future generations
I would like to emphasize two
essential dimensions of this future,
firstly
our response to climate change, a
real existential challenge
and secondly our fight against the
return  of the war in Europe this old
demon
two great challenges for sure
without obvious solution or which seems
too difficult to implement
but the history of our union
and in particular the recent history of
these last 3 years make me say to
resume
Latécoère
there is only one thing left for us to
do realize them
today
all Europeans are faced with the
reality of climate change
the data shows
that when 2022
Toulouse was the French city
most affected by climate change
so for almost  one month
temperatures have exceeded 35 degrees
science tells us we can
still limit this
dramatic transformation of our climate but time
is running out
we need to achieve
climate neutrality by 2050
so in less than 30 years
about a generation
this  is not the first time in
human history that we are
going through a major transformation
but
for the first time in history
we have an imposed deadline and a
crucial choice either we lead the change
by ourselves
or we  suffer the consequences
this means that we must act
quickly and from us that we
must act together on a
European scale and beyond on a global scale
this is the objective of our green pact
for Europe with the pact
Europe has become a global pioneer
we were the first continent
to translate objective
climate neutrality legislation into a moral obligation
we made it a legal obligation
but tackling climate change
should not just be a matter
of obligation  of obligation
it must also be about opportunities
massively investments in the
clean transition at European level
for example with our recovery plan
called next generation
40%
of these 800 billion euros will be
devoted to wines investments
linked to change
of these projects is here at your doorstep
we are helping to decarbonize a factory
here in Occitanie
in
Saint-Chély-d'Apcher it produces
steel for electric cars and
wind turbines
this company will reduce its
CO2 emissions by
44,000 tonnes per year
this equivalent equivalent to the
planting of a new forest of 200,000
trees
these investments are also
essential for the future of the
aviation sector dear to this city and this
region
today Toulouse remains a
pioneer pioneer city here you develop
the next generation of aircraft
that will be powered by clean hydrogen
this requires
large-scale investments
to reduce the cost of producing
clean hydrogen and to strengthen the
necessary infrastructure
this is why we are creating the first
bank for the  hydrogen in the world
it will be active from this year
it will mobilize investments for
the hydrogen economy and all of
Europe
including here in Toulouse throughout
Europe including here in Toulouse and
in your region
your university
is strongly focused  on the economy and
social sciences then you are very
well placed to understand the challenges
we are working on a huge
transformation that is
both ecological,
economic and social
all these dimensions count
the famous gentleman economist
you have worked on the
complementarity between the market  and
the state
the role of competition and regulation
I think the current challenge is a
good illustration of these actions
necessary
in a social market economy
like ours
we must we must encourage
massive public and
private investment in technologies  strong
clean
these are public goods
these are technologies of the future
and of course as important as the
investments
the skills
because we have to develop deploy and
maintain all these new clean
technologies
this is the
most ambitious industrial transformation of all  time
this means
access to the skills you
need in the world of work
but also the possibility of continuing to
learn throughout your career
in the 80s my price of his
sisters Jacques Delors
was already talking about a right to
learning  throughout life
it is time for this right to become a
reality
finally
we want the European economy
to win from this climate change
because it allowed me to
emphasize it if we do it well
there is no contradiction  between the
protection of the environment and the
development of our economy
to be up to the challenges of
the future our economy must be must
be both circular and sustainable
it must give back to the planet more than
we withdraw
and  region of the globe that will be the
first to develop
clean technology techniques
will come out on top and I want it to be
Europe that is
why we have developed
our industrial plan for the green pact
and now,
as lattecoère said, we are
left with nothing  only to realize it
Ladies and Gentlemen dear students
if climate change is an
existential question
the return of war in Europe is a
fundamental challenge for our
European Union and its security let
us remember
the European project was born to guarantee
peace in Europe
the return of the war in Europe
shocked the whole continent
we had all hoped that never again
Europe would see cities destroyed
by the incessant bombardments
of civilians hiding in underground shelters
and the absolute scandal of thousands
of children  displaced from their homes
this war marks the return of old
ghosts
but it is also something unprecedented
for the first time in our
history
a country is attacked because of its
desire to be part of the european family
ukrainians do not want to  'a
future dictated by Moscow they want freedom
they want democracy
they want Europe
and in response Russia launched a
full scale invasion of its neighbor
with this invasion Russia countess
Ukraine's right
to its sovereignty
and  its territorial integrity
Russia is thus attacking the Charter
of the United Nations
it is on the basis of this charter
and of international law
that the world has anchored peace and
democracy after terrible world wars
and this international order based on the
right
that is that Russia is questioning
Russia even currently a war
against democracy
against the idea founders so dear to
France and Europe that we all have the
right to freedom and equality
and yes
Russia is also waging a war
against the idea of ​​a
peaceful and democratic united Europe let us
never forget that
the
courageous Ukrainian people are not
only fighting for their country
they are also defending our own values
and that is why our union too
must show
unwavering solidarity with
Ukraine
as we have done for 16 months
and as we will continue to do
until Ukraine emerges
victorious
and let us be clear
the European Union wants peace
but  this peace must be a just peace
and it must restore Ukraine to its
borders and sovereignty
beyond peace
we must pave the way for
Ukraine to join our European Union
ukrainians are working hard to
reform modernize  their country despite the
war
allow me to cite a few examples
they are reforming their
judicial system
they are strengthening the fight
against corruption
they are modernizing their
legislation on the media
they are all there
because  they carry our union our
European Union in their hearts and in
their minds
because they sometimes know better than we
who live there what this
European union symbolizes
they are committed
body and soul
so we must support them every
step of the way by
helping them to  rebuild their country
modernize their economy and strengthen
their democracy
ladies and gentlemen and especially dear
students
Ukraine is not far from us
this war affects us all there
is exactly exactly me as
I was returning from Ukraine
a  young it always takes list
french
soldier armand
was killed by a russian missile near
his family with escaped the war in
bosnia when he was only one year old
he wanted to inform us of the horrors
of a new a man  brave
I would like to pay tribute to his memory
with all the victims of this terrible war
Armand soldier
represents the values ​​of your generation well
he was a committed young
man a young man who,
faced with the great injustices of our
time, decided to do his part
his  story is tragic and special
but not unique there
are many young Europeans who
in one way or another
choose to do something for
the world around them
I think of those of you who have
hosted for example  cream refugees
I'm thinking of the students who are demonstrating
for the climate
I'm thinking of the young people who choose to
work for companies that are
particularly committed to social issues
these personal commitments are what
bring us together they're the heart of our
democracy and that's  the engine of our
European Union
Jean Monnet
the most famous of the founders of our
union met
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry
as he recalled in his memoirs
he will never forget this meeting and
a sentence of Saint-Exupéry I quote
the most beautiful profession  men
is to unite men
quote
such was the meaning of his commitment
it is also mine and I am convinced
that you too will find the cause
that is close to your heart
for which you implement
everything you  you learned
the Europe of your generation
will only be thanks to your commitment
thank you again for the honor you have
done me and long live Europe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]